- [Voiceover] Each small
square in the diagram
has a side length of one centimeter.
So, what is the area of the figure?
So, we have this figure down here in blue,
and we want to know its area.
Area is the total space it covers.
And, we're also told that
each of these little squares
has a side length of one centimeter.
So, that means that each of these squares
is one square centimeter.
So, we can find the area by seeing
how many square centimeters
does this figure cover?
One way would be to just try
to draw the little square
centimeters and count them.
There's one square
centimeter, there's two,
and so on and keep counting them
all the way through.
Or, what we could do
is we could look at this
and try to break it into two shapes.
So we can say down here,
into two rectangles.
Down here we have one rectangle,
and up here we have a second rectangle.
And then we can find the
area of each rectangle
and add it together to find the total area
that the figure covers.
Down here on the bottom, we have two rows
of unit squares.
And each of those has one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
So, one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
So there's two rows of seven unit squares,
or seven square centimeters,
so the bottom rectangle is made
up of 14 square centimeters.
It covers 14 square centimeters.
And the top rectangle,
let's see we have one row,
two, three, four, five rows.
And each of those rows has
one, two square centimeters,
so we have five rows of two
square centimeters, or 10.
So, this top rectangle
here that we have in blue
covers 10 square centimeters,
plus the bottom rectangle
that we outlined in green
covers 14 square centimeters,
so in total,
the entire figure covers 24
square
centimeters.
So, 24 square centimeters is our area,
because area is how much
space does it cover,
and we figured out that it
covered 24 square centimeters.